everything is coming up in just a few
minutes you know it is that time of year
again and they just put our holiday
decorations up which I always love it
when they put them up I think they look
very nice he's got over $45 worth
Christmas decoration but no I think it
looks nice and I think this that looks
terrific I think they've done a terrific
job once again but there is one thing
missing it was bugging me today I was
trying to figure out what's missing from
this Christmas tableau and then I
realized what it was a tacky Christmas
sweater you got to have a tacky
Christmas sweater
I had one specially made for our
late-night set let's get it out here
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
and it just feels good this is an X X X
X X X el